it has been a whirlwind yes it has a lot
of moving parts we did want to come on
today and let everyone know that you
know it's a very sad
um
heartbreaking time for our family right
now but we still hold steadfast in our
faith todd and julie chrisley breaking
their silence after a jury found the two
guilty in their federal tax fraud case
you know i pray to god every day the
couple subtly addresses the elephant in
the room on their chrisley confessions
podcast so i know all of you guys are
wanting to
know every detail that is going on in
our lives and i have to ask that you
respect that we're not allowed to talk
about it at the present time there will
come a time to where all of it is
discussed
and
you know i think that we'll let everyone
decide what you know what their opinions
are but as of now
we cannot discuss anything other than
answer questions we can talk about
what's going on in our life
outside of what's going on in our life
and what's going on is todd and julie
are facing up to 30 years in prison
after being convicted of fraud those
convictions include conspiracy to commit
bank fraud bank fraud conspiracy to
defraud the united states and tax fraud
with julie also receiving an additional
conviction for wire fraud but despite
their legal woes they say love from
their fans is helping them get through
it we're alive and kicking and
we appreciate all of the support that we
have received from everyone
it's the
love that is
spread so far throughout this country
for our family
is is what's truly helping us to get up
each day as far as how their three kids
savannah grayson and chase are doing you
know the kids are all doing as best that
they can
um a lot of tears a lot of heartache a
lot of sorrow a lot of uh
trying to understand how how this is
where we are right now savannah's also
spoken out sharing a lengthy post along
this slideshow of family photos in the
caption she wrote a heartfelt message i
would like to ask one thing of you
please be kind this life is so cruel and
we're all doing the best we can i will
continue to stand by my family and fight
for justice justice for ourselves and
for others that the system has failed
and last year when e.t spoke with the
chrisleys savannah and chase showed that
same support if only people knew the
things that they did for people on a
day-to-day basis and
i mean they're the two most giving
people i think i've ever met in my
entire life and to see kind of what
they've taught us growing up and how to
treat people and to do the right thing
even when it's hard
all of those things were taught to us
and
the world's saying the complete opposite
about them i've never met two people
that have the character and the
integrity that my parents have so so
it's
like we've said the truth always wins
and you know what sometimes you gotta go
through the valleys to get to the top
and
we we weren't made to break we were made
to come through this